I'M A MOTHER
AND A SOCIAL WORKER.
AND I'M OPTIMISTIC ABOUT WORKING
WITH C-CZAR TODAY.
HEY, C-CZAR.
I'M PATTY.
WELCOME TO DAD ACADEMY.
- IT'S SURE NICE.
ANOTHER BOY, FINALLY.
- I'M NOT A BOY.
I'M A WOMAN.
- OH, OKAY.
I'M A WOMAN, TOO.
OOH, TOUCH MY VAGINA.
TOUCH MY VAGINA.
- I'M NOT GONNA DO THAT.
THIS IS A STANDARD-ISSUE
PSYCHOLOGICAL TESTING DOLL.
AND THIS IS WHAT C-CZAR'S
GONNA BE WORKING WITH TODAY.
- WHAT THE [bleep] IS THAT?
- THIS--
- IS THAT ANDERSON COOPER?
- WHY WOULD YOU THINK
THIS WAS ANDERSON COOPER?
- 'CAUSE HE'S WHITE
AND HE'S GOT FLAXEN HAIR.
- HE'S WHITE?
- YEAH, THAT BABY'S WHITE.
- A FATHER NEEDS TO SPEND
A LOT OF TIME WITH HIS CHILD.
- NO.
- NO?
- NO!
- OKAY, YOU'RE GONNA BE
IN THIS ROOM FOR FOUR HOURS.
- I DON'T WANT THAT BABY!
- DO YOU WANNA BE A GOOD FATHER?
- NO, I DON'T WANNA BE
A GOOD FATHER.
- DO YOU WISH YOU HAD
A GOOD FATHER?
- YEAH.
- THIS IS GONNA BE YOUR BABY
FOR THE DAY,
AND YOU'RE GONNA SPEND SOME REAL
QUALITY TIME WITH IT, OKAY?
FOR C-CZAR,
I KNEW THAT FOUR HOURS
WAS A LONG TIME.
- ♪ YEAH
- EVERYTHING'S BOLTED DOWN
IN HERE.
I CAN'T GET [bleep] OUT.
I'M CHARLES MANSON.
I WAS, LIKE, MAD ANGRY
AT EVERYTHING.
WHY DON'T
YOU STOP SMILIN'?
IF YOU A REAL BABY,
YOU'D BE CRYIN',
FILLIN' YOUR ASS
WITH [bleep].
WHAT IS INFINITY?
'CAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS
FEELS LIKE.
- IT'S BEEN TWO HOURS,
AND I'M REALLY PROUD
OF C-CZAR.
WE'RE HALFWAY HOME.
- OH, [bleep].
OH, [bleep].
CHICKEN HEAD.
BITCH ASS CHICKEN HEAD.
IN HOUR THREE,
I WAS JUST EXHAUSTED,
EMOTIONALLY DRAINED.
- YOU'RE HOLDIN' ME
BACK, BABY.
YOU'RE THE ONLY ONE
WHO UNDERSTANDS
WHAT I'M GOING THROUGH,
AND YET YOU'RE THE ONE
WHO CAUSED THIS NIGHTMARE,
BABY.
IN HOUR FOUR,
I FELL IN LOVE WITH MY SON.
- C-CZAR?
- GET THE [bleep] AWAY FROM ME.
- C-CZAR, IT'S ME, PATTY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU CAN GIVE THAT RIGHT BACK
TO ME NOW.
- WHY WOULD I GIVE YOU
MY BABY?
- WELL, IT'S NOT A REAL BABY,
OF COURSE.
- OH, YOU'RE GONNA SAY THAT
TO HIS FACE?
- THAT'S NOT A REAL--
- WHAT IS THIS, "PINOCCHILO"?
- I'M NOT CALLING
THE BABY "PINOCCHLIO."
I'M SAYING THAT WHY DON'T
YOU GIVE THAT BABY
A BIG OLD HUG
AND GIVE IT ON BACK TO ME, OKAY?
- OKAY.
[inhales]
[blows raspberry]
OW!
IT'S STUCK TO MY LIP RING!
DON'T--GET AWAY FROM ME!
GET AWAY FROM ME!
THIS BABY'S--
- C-CZAR, DON'T MOVE.
- AHH!